Cool.
Maybe let me just send a message.
But we are now on YouTube. So don't
say anything about me that says I'm unprofessional
or rubbish. Alright? Let's save that for afterwards.
It's
really frustrating, but we are live. We're on
YouTube. We'll get started in just a moment.
Alright, everyone has been emailed. Let's see what
happens.
Sorry about that, but we are
now gonna get started.
So let's say hello in the chat.
Alright.
Well,
Stefan.
Thank you for taking time out of your
day to join me on the session,
talk about Timoni and work on a live
demo.
So could you please take a few moments
just to let people know who you are,
what you're up to, and then we'll kick
things off.
Sure.
Hi, folks. I'm Stefan.
I'm a
long
term Flux maintainer.
If you don't know Flux, it's a CNC
project that does GitOps thingies.
And,
yeah, roughly
nine months ago, I started a new site
project
called Timoni,
which is
like Helm, but not Helm.
Doesn't do YAMLs,
but QLang.
And yeah,
works quite nicely with Kubernetes.
Uses all the new shiny things in the
Kubernetes API
that I've been,
yeah,
working with inside the Flux project for the
last two years.
So,
yeah, I'm very happy to share with you
my project.
And, yeah, hopefully, people will get excited about
it.
Awesome. Well, I do have lots of questions,
but I know you've got some slides. So
why don't you share your screen? We'll start
with that, and I'll throw my questions at
you as we work our way through that.
And then for everyone watching us on YouTube,
the demo will follow shortly after the slides.
So we will be getting hands on and
showing you how Timoni works in practice.
Cool.
Yeah. So,
Timoni.
I called it a package manager. And we
are going to see through the slides what
makes Timoni a package manager. But before I'm
getting there,
I wanted to frame a little bit
how I'm thinking about Timoni. And I basically
put
people in two categories.
The first category is
software makers,
like, I don't know, software vendors
that are
trying to ship their
cloud native apps onto
clients' clusters,
and of course, open
source maintainers.
There are so many open source projects out
there for
extending Kubernetes,
like CID controllers and so on.
And also platform engineers. So this group of
people and organizations
will want to, you know, distribute applications
onto
end users' clusters or environments.
So that's one category that Timoni tries to,
improve
their workflow there, how you
alter
your app definition
and how you distribute that to everybody.
And the second group are
end users, Kubernetes users,
can be developers,
operators,
people that want to use
well known defined upstream packages for a particular
app or controller or
complex systems. And they want to
make use of that to deploy it on
their own infrastructure.
So
I think
these two
thinking of users in this way, it's quite
common for any package manager out there. Someone
creates the package for an application and someone
else uses it.
But with Kubernetes, it's not always
like that. Usually,
these two groups can be a single group.
If
you
are
a platform engineer or if you are a
developer in your own organization,
you may
have to create a distribution for your own
app. And sometimes you also manage that app.
You deploy it on different clusters.
So
this group can be one.
Okay. So
what is Timoni? As I said, it's a
package manager. It's
basically a command line tool.
It's written in Golang.
It's a static binary built for Mac OS,
Linux, Windows. And it has no dependencies
on anything on your operating system.
And it embeds
three core technologies.
QLANK.
So basically,
Timoni comes, built with the Q engine inside.
So it heavily relies on QLANK for
when
you
write your app definition, you'll be writing it
in queue. When you want to deploy
that particular app, you can also
write the deployment, how you configure it, and
so on in queue. But for end users,
CUE is not a hard requirement. You can
also
write the configuration in a YAML file or
a JSON file and so on.
So
that's
one thing that powers Timoni,
Keylang.
The second one
is the
Open Container Initiative
standards.
And what standard Timoni heavily relies on are
OCI artifacts. So what are OCI artifacts? There
are these things that look like a container
image,
but inside is not a container image, can
be
custom
configuration.
In Timoni's case, what's in the OCI artifact
are
CUE definitions.
Timoni has its own OCI
artifact type
and
is compatible
with almost all container registries out there.
They got to a point where OCI artifacts
are
are the standard, and they are accepted almost
everywhere.
And third, of course, is Kubernetes.
Timoni
deploys everything on Kubernetes.
I didn't get Timoni to Lambdas or anything
else.
Get. You mean get. Yeah. Yeah.
Never know.
The idea here is that Timoni
tried to use this Kubernetes
API
using the latest and greatest innovation inside Kubernetes.
And more specifically, Timoni relies on Kubernetes server
side applied,
which is a thing that it's generally available
in Kubernetes
since
two years now. So you shouldn't have an
issue using Timoni.
You're probably running
a Kubernetes version that understands
this type of operations. So
how this makes Timoni different to
other
tools out there is the fact that
Timoni,
every time it tries to deploy an app,
it will ask the cluster
it will ask the cluster for the
parent state
and it will compare the cluster state with
the desired state to what's in the app
definition.
And it will only apply
changes
by correcting the state. So you have like
hundreds of deployments,
but you only change one of it,
unlike Helm and other tools, Timoni will only
apply that change. So it will be very,
very fast if you
do small changes and frequent changes.
Okay. Next. So
what makes Timoni a
package manager are
these four
core concepts around
applications. So first, it allows you to define
an app.
You distribute that definition.
You can
compose
an app from multiple definitions. For example, you
have microservices.
The app concept is
a bundle of all these microservices.
Maybe you have a distributed monolith. It's also
a composition of things.
So it has this feature of allowing you
to compose things and that's how your app
comes into being. And finally, lifecycle management,
which is the core thing that any
package manager should do. Should be able to
install things, upgrade things, uninstall it,
roll back, and and all these things which
we can call lifecycle management.
Okay, so let's do a deep dive into
those.
So app definition,
what
that means.
How do you define an app for Kubernetes
in most cases, normal cases, right? You'll have
a bunch of YAML files on the disk
with all sorts of settings in there, like
Kubernetes deployment, the service and so on. But
that representation,
all these YAMLs on a disk are
one way of how that app can be
deployed on a cluster. You need to change
things. You need to allow your end users
to fiddle
with limits or enable
some feature in your app in
the config map or things like that.
So how do you achieve it in our
current day? You have to have some kind
of templating engine. Right? Or you can use
customizing
and ship a bunch of overlays to your
end users, which I haven't seen it done
that much.
So it
boils down to
be able to
have a good app definition engine, you need
a templating engine.
And the templating engine that
Timoni chose and is built inside is QLang.
And what that brings to Timoni's
Timoni's users is having type safe Kubernetes templates.
I'm going to explain a little bit what
that means later on.
So
you define your app with typesafe Kubernetes templates,
then you allow your users to
customize it in all possible ways. But you
have total control of what the end user
can change to your app.
You control what you expose,
what you allow them to do. And more
importantly, you also can configure defaults,
good defaults
for your app and so on. So have
the app definition then
of course, how are end users going to
use that app definition? Well, the package manager
has to have some kind of distribution mechanism.
The distribution mechanism for Timoni are
container registries.
And I think it's kind of natural
these days because
any app that runs on Kubernetes
in a way has to is composed out
of one or multiple container images.
The app runs in a container, that runs
in a pod, and so
So
all software vendors out there already have a
container registry,
or they are pushing their apps to the
client container registry.
So in order to distribute
app definitions,
you can reuse that registry, which is already
there. You have figured it out how to
scale it, how to run it, and so
on. Right? So you can push to the
same container registry where your app images are,
the Timoni packages.
And Timoni packages have two
properties.
Timoni modules
are semantically versioned.
And this is enforced by the system. Timoni
will not allow you to
publish a new app definition
without having a valid Sembr
for it. And why Sembr is important
is not because
people have figured out Sambr. No, it's not
that. For
me, Sambr is more about ordering
than anything else.
You can determine what's the latest version by
just looking at
and it's quite easy.
Now,
using SemVol the right way, you, oh, I'm
making a breaking change. I'm bumping the major
version. Version. Well, not many people do it.
I mean, doesn't. It's on one point something,
and any final release comes with some breaking
change.
But
still, server as a means of
telling your user, this is a release candidate
or this is a stable version, it's quite
important that I went with that.
Timoni also wants to ensure immutability
and a container registry
does not enforce that by default. If you
use, like Timoni uses the version to set
the image tag in the registry.
And you can override it. You can push
now version 1.0.0
and later on say, oh, going to push
again 1.0.0.
This
is also an issue with Helm and container
images in general.
So how Timoni tries to solve this, it
allows the end user
to specify the version, but also the digest.
And the digest in a container registry is
immutable. And what Timoni will do, will compare
the version with the digest that the user
expects.
And if
that doesn't match it, it will not deploy
that modulator and it will say to the
end user, hey, you wanted this version
with this digest, but this is they are
no longer matching. So it can just delete
the version from there and work with Timoni
just to digest. I know this is not
human friendly.
You can't just look at the digest and
understand it, but for machine is really great
and you should be pinning things using digest
and Timoni tries to make that
not also for modules, but also for container
images. And I'll mention that later on. Yeah,
and also modules can be cryptographically
signed. That's also very important and you can
verify it. Timoni fully integrates
right now with cosign
keyless or with static keys.
So how does a bundle look like? How
does a module look like? What What the
software vendor, what the
open source maintainer has to create inside the
repo? So you'll
have this kind of structure. It is a
directory.
You can
initialize
all of this with a simple command,
Timoni Mode in it.
Creates this kind of structure. And if you
look at it, it
resembles a little bit with Helm. I tried
to
preserve
the templates directory,
but that is the only resemblance.
And of course, it has a README where
you should definitely put in there all the
documentation
around your module.
And the structure here
is very specific to QLAN. What
is a Timoni module is, in fact, a
QLAN module with a
more open ended structure.
QLAN is,
if you're not familiar with it, is this
language that tries to unify all types of
configuration. You can generate configuration, you can
validate configuration,
you can also generate code.
You can do even scripting with it.
So
it's very flexible. It allows you to do
a bunch of things.
But this kind of flexibility
also means that,
you know, it's quite hard to get started
and figure it out and so on. So
Timoni comes with very strict ways of how
modules are defined, how they are structured. So
it brings some kind of
it's uniform.
No
matter what repo you'll be looking at that
has a Timoni module, have to have this
structure and it will have to have
particular files with different functions. For example,
you need to have a templates directory
and in every templates directory, you have a
config.
Q, which contains
a Q definition of what type of configuration
your app
allows.
And it also contains the schema and the
constraints.
And all of that is put in there.
And then you have Timoni ignore and so
on,
all these things
that are here.
But
the idea is that
your module will contain
schemas.
For example, all the Kubernetes API schemas.
So if you
want to define a Kubernetes deployment, you'll be
using the upstream Kubernetes deployment
schema,
which is very different from
other templating engines.
Why is it different? Because once you
use a schema,
then you know that template is type safe.
You can you can add there a field,
let's say replicas,
and you make a typo and you don't
type, last
test.
Running a Timoni vet, Timoni will tell you,
hey, this field is not in deployment. You
can't set this field.
So
all those
problems where you are just
templating over
a text, which is some kind of YAML,
are quite gone.
Are
way safer using schemas because they are strict
and all these fields are validated without
you having to
apply all the time to Kubernetes cluster and
test if these things are okay or not.
And Timoni goes even further
than just
offering
type safe
schemas and
templates for Kubernetes
native objects. You can also
embed in your modules Kubernetes CRDs.
And Timoni has a command where you give
it a
CRD definition, let's say, I don't know, certificate
from cert manager.
And it will generate a schema for you.
And when you define a certificate, it will
have the same validation
to know all the fields, all the possible
values of those fields and so on.
So this is like a
major step in the direction where
more and more controllers are there and
now it's quite common to ship your application,
not only with Kubernetes
standard APIs, but also making
use of all these extensions, all these custom
resource definitions.
So yeah, that's how a module looks like.
Timoni comes with the
whole set of commands for creating
a module from scratch, that's in it,
verifying the module web.
You can build it and see the final
YAML or the final JSON.
You can
import
Kubernetes schemas
by just setting the Kubernetes version, and these
are curated schemas
that I've published on GitHub. And you can
also, as I said, vendor any CRD you
have there by just giving Timoni the
YAML of that CRD or the URL of
that CRD.
And of course it comes with commands for
you to actually run end to end tests
like is my deployment. Okay, my deployment is
valid. It has all these things, but what
about will it work on a cluster?
So it has the supply command. You can,
that
works with local
modules. You don't have to push them to
a container registry and you can do all
sorts of tests and create our own end
to end test grid in CI and so
on.
For distributions,
there are also dedicated commands like module push,
module pull, module ls, which will query the
container register, gives you all the versions, all
their digests.
It also comes with some helper functions like
registry login and logout in case you don't
have a
Docker CLI or a Crane CLI locally.
And it also allows you to sign and
verify
modules
when you do a push and when you
do a pull.
Nice.
Any
ideas, David, so far?
How do you like it?
I mean, it takes all the boxes for
me. Right? Because let's go back to everything
you've covered so far.
I've not made it a secret on my
YouTube channel. Right? I'm not a fan of
Helm. And it's not because Helm
does any one thing particularly
bad.
It's because it's YAML and because Go templating,
in my opinion, just isn't good enough. It's
a horrible syntax unless you've written a lot
of Go code before, which used to be
true, right, in Kubernetes ecosystem. Everyone that was
in the Kubernetes space had written a plenty
of Go code, probably used the template and
language. They were fine. But as more people
came,
I spent a lot of my time helping
people understand Go templates rather than just
and, hey. Use this or to, like, Ginger
or handlebar syntax. Everybody's familiar with this now.
Go templates
resemble a little bit until it doesn't. Like,
the special dot syntax and the way that,
you know, trimming white spaces. There's loads of
weird quirks. However, I'm not gonna bash about
Helm because Helm has also
helped us get to where we are today.
Of course. I I feel that there has
to be something better. And the minute I
seen Timoni
and I saw that it is CUE and
it was used in OCI,
like it's just like stars in my eyes.
I was like, this is this is what
I wanted. This is this is like if
I could build something and I had the
the well to set and do it, this
is exactly what I wanna see and what
I want to see. So I was very
happy.
I came into this knowing the problem space,
knowing that I like CUE
and knowing that OCI is where we need
to be for the, you know, future facing
get ups delivery pipelines.
But let's assume there are people watching that
are interested in Timoni, they haven't maybe got
that experience with CUE. I would love to
know from you,
you being the person that made all of
these decisions as one, why did you say
that you had to write a new tool?
And why did you just say that CUE
would be the substrate or the, you know,
the the primitive for building that new tool?
Yeah. I mean,
I I got to queue out of frustration
or
writing Helm Chats, and I wrote a lot
of them. And I still maintain a lot
of them.
Hell will not go away anytime soon.
And
I tried
over the years
several technologies that
tried to enter this space and of failed.
I think JSONED was the closest one. And
there
were different projects
back in the day that are dead right
now. I think the only one still alive
and kicking is from Grafana,
Tanga.
Yeah. I
JSON didn't stick with me.
I'm frank. I mean, it's powerful. It's nice.
But I don't know. I couldn't deal with
JSON schemas on top of JSON and other
JSONs.
And so, yeah. It was like
I think what yeah. You're you're right. Like,
I think one of the challenges with JSON
at JSON, I don't even know how to
pronounce it right. But
it
was familiar enough if you didn't do anything
JSON at ish and you just talk to
JSON. But the minute you wanted to start
using their functions and the other features that
made it as powerful as it it was,
it became so alien so quickly that you
just really, oh, this this node doesn't feel
like something I'm comfortable with anymore. And that
was always one of my struggles been trying
to work with it for sure.
Yeah. For
me it was like,
okay, who uses it right now? And I
I've seen that the Prometheus team is a
big fan of of JSON. And I looked
at JSON
for
deploying Prometheus operator and some Grafana dashboards. I
yeah, I said, what? It wasn't for me.
I don't know. I don't want to say
it's not for everybody. Lots of people use
it and love it, but
it didn't stick with me. Then,
I don't know, years later,
two years ago, I was at KubeCon Valencia.
Someone came to me at the Flux booth
and said, hey, we migrated all our charts
and all our
customized overlay to Keylang. I said, Okay,
I knew about Keylang. I went to their
website,
I don't know, maybe two years, three years
and a half ago.
It looked very similar to Go with J.
Wow, I do Go, I don't know, eight
years now.
But then when I looked at their docs,
it felt like, I don't know, the docs
were written for
language authors,
for academic people. And I looked at that.
And I yeah,
I didn't continue.
I almost forgot about it.
Then this person that came to me, Varesha,
we talked a lot. I think we talked
about half
an hour or something. And he really convinced
me to go back home and
give it another shot. And
it took a while
for
me to really
like CUE. And
because that person was so convincing, like, was,
like, so enthusiastic about it,
Every time I said, Okay, I'm going to
close this and go back to Flux doing
my customized controller
or whatever, I said, Okay, but maybe I
should try more. And yeah, after a while,
really clicked at some point.
And I started
doing more and more things in CUE, understand
better the language.
I think for me,
advantage was that Q itself, the language and
the engine is written in Go. And if
I couldn't
quite figure out why is this happening, would
I could just go in the source code
and read it. And
read their unit test, which was very, very
helpful. Like
even if the documentation wasn't great back then,
they had like
really good test coverage. I could really understand
what's going on. And I'm that type of
person that
likes to read code to understand the tool.
I know
not everybody should even think about that. It's
not good for your health, but anyway.
That's me, yeah. And what I really liked
about
CUE, and I'm
very fond of it, is the immutability part,
which I really, really
dislike around
how Helm, Customize and all these other templating
languages are
running. Like you can set a value
in base, you set replicas one. Then in
some other template you do an if and
you say, oh, replicas here are three. And
some later on in your logic, at some
point you remove replicas altogether,
stuff like that.
Which is fun because you have so much
freedom,
you can do whatever,
but when you need to debug this stuff,
it's a nightmare, right? Well, CUE is not
like that. Once you set a field,
that's it. If you try to remove it
or set it to another value, it will
say, hey,
this field is already set. It has this
value.
So in a way, even if at first
I felt really mad about it, like
why couldn't I just override this field? How
can this be a template
engine if I can't override things?
And then I understood why this is good,
right? Because it makes you for
a Timoni module, right? You really need to
define all the things in your options in
the config file, and you can only set
defaults to them. You can set
replicas to interdeployment
queue file, and then in the config set
a default to five, and somewhere else, like
if something, set it to seven and so
And even if it's annoying at first, it
forces
you to create a good structure and expose
only the right things to the end users.
And also for them, it's easier to configure
your app because there is one way to
do it, not 1,000,000 ways.
And of course, customized patches, right? You have
a base, you have an overlay, but then
you can create another
overlay on top of that overlay, and so
on.
Even if it's flexible,
this type of
hacking almost with all these objects
becomes really, really hard to debug in the
end. And
with CUE, you have these constraints, so
you need to understand the constraints. You need
to
be Okay with them. And afterwards,
things will look better.
The end result will be better, if you
want.
So yeah,
I'm not saying getting started with Timoni is
hard, but
it can be a challenge coming from
customizing
role because you'll try to apply the same
principles, and in there it will not work.
So
yeah, it has a steep
learning curve, but more about you need to
change a little bit how you think about
configuration and templates.
Awesome.
Yeah. That was a great description
of CUE and some of its challenges. Right?
You you said the word academic,
which was was spot on. I remember the
first time I looked at the CUE documentation
and I was like, isn't for me because
don't understand all this terminology. The lexicon is
just above my pay grade at some capacity.
Like, I need to know what that disjunction
is to understand the unification model of the
CUE block. Like like, sorry. I just wanted
to describe some Kubernetes resources.
And I think they're getting better there. You
know, it was a very academic project and
I think now it's starting to find a
bit more traction and they are trying to
sand off these rough edges, make it easier
to consume and just use it as what
it's used for without understanding what's going on
under the hood. And I do completely agree
with what you said. It forces you to
understand where things become
options or configuration
for your CUE value object and you have
to explicitly
make these things that people can consume via
definitions, private fields, whatever. And you never
said this directly, but I think it's important
and that kind of underpins everything that you
said you liked about CUE.
The schema definition live right next to the
values themselves. That's where the unification comes in.
Like, the schema all gets merged together to
give you some sort of concrete value.
And I I think that is something that
could throw people off at first, but then
once you understand that dynamic, it becomes a
bit of a superpower too because you can
arbitrarily throw around definitions and expose them to
people and then take an input objects and
all this other wonderful stuff. So people will
see when we get to the hands on
bit for sure but Yeah. Yeah. I mean
having schemas,
constraints,
and values all in one thing
is clearly overwhelming
for someone that starts today,
and
for Timoni,
you need to get into this as a
module
author when you write your
app package as a Timoni module. But for
end users,
I'm not exposing them to this type of
complexity.
For end user, when you configure the app
to deploy it,
you don't
write any schemas,
you don't deal with defaults, you don't deal
with constants, you just
give Timoni concrete
values,
like I want replicas two,
horizontal pod autoscaler max five and so on.
And then Timoni injects the schemas,
runs the constraints and it will say,
hey, you are setting replicas two,
max replicas
five and max replicas three. This is not
okay.
So
I'm trying to
not
expose the end user to all this complexity
because all this complexity is really needed on
the other side when you compose your app
definition, not when you use it. When you
use it, it should be very, very simple.
And
yeah, we'll see
how easy it is when you do the
kickstart.
Okay.
Last two things about package management. So we
see that, okay, Timoni allows you to define
your app with Q templates.
You can distribute those to container registries with
OCR artifacts.
But
how would end users, how would Kubernetes users,
developers, you know, everybody that has to do
something in
Kubernetes,
how are they going to consume it? And
there are two major
cracks here. One is app composition
where
you basically never deploy something alone. Maybe it
has a dependency. Maybe your app needs a
Redis server for the caching or
the app that you are deploying is made
out of multiple
microservices.
Some are optional, some are not, right? So
with Helm, we have these umbrella charts and
so on. I want
to build that into Timoni at all.
In Timoni, there is a different approach on
how you do app compositions and it's not
about writing modules. And we'll see how that
works. It's called Timoni bundle. But the idea
is you can bundle multiple things
to have your
app as you want it. And
another
important feature of
package management and what Timoni also does is
lifecycle management.
You
can install it, you can upgrade it, you
can roll it back, you can reconfigure it,
you can run end to end tests after
an upgrade or after an install,
and all of these things have to be
like
straightforward,
easy to use, and
we'll see
how that goes.
So how do you compose things?
How do you, you as an end user,
how you add
configuration,
how you specify modules and so on.
This is done through a Timoni bundle definition,
which is a CUE file.
The same representation can be done with a
YAML file or JSON.
But yeah, I definitely
prefer CUE also on this side because Timoni
comes with some nice
features when you use CUE for definitions.
So what is a bundle? A bundle is
a file where you list instances.
What is an instance? You can think of
an instance as a for
example. It's an instantiation
of a module on your cluster.
So a bundle is made out of one
instance. If you deploy a single app with
no dependency or nothing, or a bundle can
be made out of multiple instances.
And here the example is
I'm deploying Podinfo,
which is
a toy app that I made a long
time ago.
And this app needs a cache server, which
is optional, but you can also deploy to
the cache server. So instead of having Redis
as
embedded in the Podinfo module,
you would deploy Redis from its own module,
deploy
pod info from its own module, and then
you can have shared configuration
between them. In this case, I want to
pass the password
from the runtime
because I don't want to hard code here
in
CUE files, any kind of sensitive information. So
I'm defining
and you can define any type of input.
Here is just a simple string password comes
from the runtime. Then I'm using this in
string interpolation to set up the Redis URL
for the info. And I'm also using it
in the Redis configuration where I explicitly
set up the password. Here is the value
of it.
And
another thing to notice here,
modules are referenced by an URL which is
like a container image in Kubernetes,
but has an OCI prefix. So it's clear
that it's an
address to a container registry.
And you can reference a particular version. If
you don't specify the version at all, Timoni
will use latest.
But
as I said before, you can also refer
to modules
by upstream digest, so you ensure that no
matter how,
when you run this bundle, it will always
use that particular version, even if tags
are
mutable in the registry, you can refer it
by digest.
So yeah, this is how
you would be using Timoni. You'll create these
bundle files and you'll apply them and yeah,
and Timoni will do all the deployment for
you and so on.
So Timoni has commands
specifically
for bundles.
They start with Timoni bundle something. You
can verify them, you can build them, you
can apply them,
you can
do dry runs and diffs
every time you do an upgrade. Maybe you
are not sure what things will change on
the cluster
with that upgrade, so you should do a
bundle apply with minus minus diff. I want
to show you a nice
diff of the Kubernetes objects, only the fields
that are changing,
and you can query the status. Of course,
you can delete it.
And you can also
distribute bundles,
which are Q files and other things through
a container registry.
As a platform admin,
maybe you want to create
bundles for
cluster add ons, and those look the same
everywhere, maybe the password or whatever input is
different,
But if you want to share with other
well
known configurations,
you can also push bundles
and any type of Qt definition
to a container registry. And there is this
Timoni artifact command,
which has pull, push, list, and so on,
like modules. But the main difference here is
that if modules,
for modules,
you need to use SAMLER, and they are
SAMLERD
artifacts,
it's free for all. You can do whatever
you want here because these are snippets
that you'll be sharing,
So it's up to you if you want
to use a mutable tag and so on.
In any case, you can also do a
pull using a digest and so on. But
yeah,
the artifacts
commands are
a way right now to work around
the lack of
package management in the queue language itself.
And
I want to explain a little bit what
this means.
Timoni has, for example,
helpers.
There are some
Q schemas, for example, for defining container images,
for defining Kubernetes metadata with the right labels,
with app Kubernetes labels. So you
want to ensure some kind of good defaults
and you want to have helpers so you
don't have to type all this Q code
on your own. So you build your
little
CUE library. Now,
if
someone makes a different bundle on their own
repo,
the only way right now with CUE is
they need to copy paste all the files
or do
some magic with git and symlinks.
I don't want that.
So
this is where Timoni Artifact Push and Pull
comes into place. You can share
snippets of CUE code packages and so on.
But the CUE team is actively
working on shipping
package management inside CUE for
the language itself. And
I'm very happy with it. They went with
OCI as well. So at some point you'll,
the future will
not have to use the Timoni artifact push
command.
Will
able to do this with Q alone and
share
code between
modules like that. But until then, this command
that
you can definitely use it today.
So I'm curious.
I know I I don't wanna ask too
many questions before we get the terminal open
and get hands on and stuff. But, you
know,
the CUE modules
the the the CUE module stuff that the
CUE team are working on would be to
push
arbitrary
CUE to an OCI and then be able
to pull that down and
build,
you know, queue values based on all of
that stuff together.
I mean, with the Timoni artifacts be different
from that with different metadata, different
configuration or would it are you just gonna
use directly what the CUE team build? Like,
it feels like they're different, but maybe similar.
So Timoni
the Timoni artifacts command can be used to
distribute
reusable
CUE packages.
Right. Okay. And that part,
I hope,
can be totally replaced
upstream
using
QGET,
like GoGET,
and that part will be
will work
with the CUE toolchain
itself.
But
Timoni Artifact will still be useful if you
want to distribute Timoni
bundles and runtimes as well on configuration everywhere,
because then you can pipe you can do
Timoni artifact
pool pipe
Timoni bundle
apply
from standard in, right? So
it's a hacky way of using artifacts now
to distribute things that CUE itself should distribute,
but I made these commands for distributing
well known configuration of bundles
in the same way as you do with
modules.
The idea is you push your container image,
the code that's running to the container registry.
You push the module, which is
how that app can be installed. And then
you can push a bundle with
secure first defaults.
This is how it should be run,
or examples of best known configuration.
Got it. Thank you.
Okay, and the last thing that
bundle
supports are
multi cluster
deployments. And this is something that
right now is supported as I'm presenting it
here. But there is a proposal on the
Timoni
repo on how I'm seeing this in the
future, how I want to improve it.
The idea behind this is that
a bundle
can express
all the different configurations
of
one app across
your whole cluster, Philippe. And you don't have
to have different bundle files or something like
that. You can write a little program in
CUE where
all the different configurations,
all the differences between how an app
must be configured across environments can be embedded
in a single file.
And
with customize, for example, this type of
customization
means you'll need
three overlays,
the base one, staging one production. Oh, if
you want to do customization based on cluster
name, then you'll
have
other overlays for each cluster that
import the production overlay and it gets to
this,
very
messy
file distribution.
You need directories with files inside, other files,
directories on top of directories.
And this is what Flux does today with
Customize.
This is what everybody does with Customize. It
works. It's great. It's pure declarative. You have
all these directories on top of those.
You have the overlay system. But
with Timoni, I want to
give people a way to write this in
a more compact form
and
have the expression
of your app across
environments in a single file. Of course, you
can split this bundle into different files and
Timoni will do a CUE unify of all
these files so you can have these overlays
if you want, but if you don't and
if you want to have
everything expressed in a single file, can do
it because CUE allows it. You can write
if conditions,
you can
with Timoni runtime environments, can take input from
outside, from other clusters,
from your local environment. And based on that,
you can create
this little program that
knows how to deploy your app everywhere.
And what
I'm trying to do next is,
based on
this, is allowing
people to have
in a
different CUE file, which is called a runtime
file,
where you can list all your clusters along
with the CUE context for each cluster. So
you don't have to do
Timoni apply bundle minus minus context production,
because
this is how it works today. And the
problem with this is,
if you mess up your context, you'll end
up applying
the
dev configuration
on the production cluster or something like that.
Right? There are many tools to switch context.
You can put the context in a CUE
environment
variable and so on. And it's
quite easy to mess it up. So I
want to add to Timoni a way of
you to declare all the clusters that you
have and specify there the context. So you'll
only do apply
-f this file and Timoni will know, oh,
these are all the clusters I need to
execute them with this particular order,
dev first, if that goes Okay, go to
staging, go to production finally. And do this
progressive
deployment
of the bundle across the cluster fleet. And
yeah, if anyone is interested in how this
will shape out, there is an issue
on
the Timoni repo.
Okay. Timoni versus Helm.
We've
touched a little bit around this.
There is also a dedicated page on the
Timoni website, Comparison Help, where
it's quite a big list there of all
the differences.
I wanted here to just showcase
some of the performance
differences and
how Timoni
is, let's say,
more performant, more efficient than Helm just because
it uses
the technology in a different way. For example,
Timoni does not
store all your
YAMLs in Kubernetes secrets.
What Helm does every time you do a
Helm upgrade,
even if the upgrade modifies just a tiny
bit of YAML,
what Helm will do, it will
get all your YAMLs in your chart, and
it will store that in a new secret.
And you end up with, I don't know,
ten, twenty, one hundred secrets, whatever you can
set the limit for those as well. But
the idea is you always have
the
manifest twice. Once in ETCD
and
yet again in a secret. And if you
version it, you do multiple upgrades, you'll end
up with all these things. And
if you do a simple load test, let's
say you do a Helm upgrade in a
loop 100 times,
you'll see
gigabytes of data going between the CLI, the
Helm CLI, and the Kube API. And you
can see the amount of pressure Helm puts
on the Kubernetes API.
And
yeah, my
approach to this is
I don't want to store
all these
things twice in the cluster,
because
the module
definition
is already in your repository,
in your container repository.
And what Timoni does when it creates an
instance,
it stores
in the cluster your custom values, because those
really matter,
and the digest and the URL to the
module. So if you need to roll back,
if you need to apply an earlier version,
you can just reference
that digest.
Of course, it's
not the same as
does it, because even if you delete a
chart,
the
YAMLs in that chart are already stored in
a cluster. So you can do a restore
without having to pull the chart.
But if the chart goes away and the
container images go away, you delete the container
repo.
Then
the rollback will still fail because the images
are gone.
Right? So
why the hell doesn't even make a copy
of all the images, right? That's a real
rollback. You need to copy everything in a
way. So my approach to this is Timoni
also creates a secret as a storage. It
doesn't store there.
It doesn't store there YAML. It only stores
the Q values that the end user created.
And a list of
references,
which is kind, name, namespace, API version, to
all the things that it manages. So this
is like a tiny bit of data
so Timoni can do all things.
You can see
what resources it manages,
what's their status.
If you want to
go back, restore the current version, if you
do a kubectl editor or something, you have
the
module digest there so you can reapply it.
So that's one main difference between how
Timoni and Helm works around
state persistence.
Another difference
in regards to performance is
what I mentioned before.
You have huge
app definitions with hundreds
thousands
of
manifests in there. And if you do an
upgrade which only changes
one deployment, Timoni will only apply that change.
While on every upgrade, it will apply everything.
And you can see how that can be
really impactful for your Kubernetes API.
Okay. If you want to find out more,
there are many, many differences.
I try to keep this list up to
date. And it's on comparison
on the website.
Some resources.
How can you contribute Timoni? Well, Timoni is
Apache two point zero
licensed.
It accepts
contributions
on GitHub with pull requests.
But I think
code contributions
are great, but they are not
the most valuable thing you can contribute. I
think
at this point, the most valuable thing is
trying it out. Try to write your own
modules
and give feedback on that. And if
you create some modules, share it with others.
They are like, I'm not going to translate
all the 1,000,000 Helm charts out there. I'm
not going to do that because Timoni is
just a side project.
I work on it ten nights and weekends.
I don't have time to do all of
that. And I know there are Timoni users
right now which have
fully migrated from the inherent charts to Timoni
modules.
But yeah, there are so many things
out there that could be
distributed as modules. And I think that's the
most important thing. Feedback on that,
how hard it is to
create
a module. I'm quite sure there are so
many UX improvements around authoring
and helping people
write CUE, generate all this code. CUE is
quite challenging
when you have schemas and all the things
that we said. I'm
also considering having
dedicated
docs in the Timoni website around modules,
and maybe
have a get started with CUE as well.
Specifically for Kubernetes, not all the configuration out
there, right? And
I would really appreciate help from
anyone who can
build a get started with QNT money guide
or something like that.
I think it's
quite more important than someone
hardcore code contributions,
which are nice, but
it's not the only way you can contribute.
Okay. That was it, presentation.
It took some time.
Let's
get the hands on.
Exactly.
Alright. So thank you so much for for
walking through that. We have a couple of
questions
from YouTube. However,
I think those questions will be best answered
by us just getting the terminal open and
actually showing it. So
to Stefan and to YMO,
your questions are great and I'd rather show
you the answers as we play with
Timoni. However, I'm gonna be really selfish and
ask one of my own questions because, you
know, that's
because you talked about
valuable contributions that are gonna come from people
writing Timoni modules and making it easier for
other people to onboard to Timoni without having
to write everything themselves. Right? The first question
that pops into my head the minute you
said that was, well, first,
yes, let's get people doing that. But what's
the discovery mechanism?
Are you currently talking to anyone at like
the the CNCF or Artifact Hub in order
to get Timoni listed there? Has it already
listed there and I missed it? Like how
do people find these modules when they do
exist?
Yeah. That's a
a great question. I have an issue about
so
Artificial Hub is definitely
a great way of
being able to discover things without locking people
into
a unique registry or
my own registry or something. I don't want
to have Timoni as NPM. I don't want
to be the person that runs
the
authorized registry and everybody has to push there
and so on. The whole idea of distributing
Timoni modules with OCI artifacts is the idea
that you will be pushing your modules next
to your app image. I don't
want to host your app images, right?
And it also makes it very easy to
replicate it. Like for example, AWS has public
ECR,
which mirrors a bunch of things from Docker
Hub. When Docker Hub goes down, you can
switch to that, right? This could, you could
apply the same thing to Timoni modules. You
push the Timoni modules to Docker Hub, and
you can push it to ECR public, to
GCR, and so on.
I use
GitHub Container Registry because it's so easy for
me to publish there from GitHub itself.
But it works everywhere.
And the discovery part is quite challenging when
you have all these modules everywhere distributed and
so on. And I will definitely need some
help for someone which is intimate with, has
some knowledge about Artifact Hub.
I see that Tecton and other projects have
registered their
OCI type. It's no different than that.
Timoni has its own OCI, artifact type,
and layer type.
Standard annotations,
which are all from
OCI standard annotations.
I didn't come up with anything
special there.
So yeah,
Artifact Hub is
one way of doing it, and I will
really need some help there. Another idea that
I had is
run
a public instance, a different instance of Artify
Hub only with Timoni
OCI artifact in there
and use that UI to only search Timoni
things.
Who knows? But yeah, Artify Hub will be
a first
good step forward.
Yeah.
Alright.
Well, I'm going to share my screen and
let's start kicking the tires.
Alright. You should be able to see my
web browser now. This is the Timoni homepage.
If you wanna check this out and play
with it yourself, you go to tonomi.sh.
As always,
we first need to install the tool.
So I'm just going to grab the brew
command
jump over to my terminal and get this
kicked off.
But we're gonna do two things today if
I remember correctly, Stefan. We are going to
work through the quick start gate
and then after we get through to the
end, hopefully get people answers to all of
their questions. We're gonna try and show more
of
production use case by making this work with
like, you know, secrets and other things that
become important
when you stop playing with the tool and
start deploying with the tool.
Oh, I don't even realize the brookie man
was right here in front of me too.
Oh, well.
Yeah. In the install page,
there are many other ways
outside Brew. I discovered, for example, that Open
SUSE
team has published a Timoni module for
an RPM
package on their
repository and so on. So, yeah, I've Nice.
There is a mix
package,
a YI package,
an arcade package,
Alex,
from Open Files added to arcade.
Hopefully, at some point, someone will contribute it
to
the Windows
ecosystem. It works on Windows, but you have
to download the binary now. I know Windows
has its own
package management.
I'm not sure how to do that. Yeah.
Alright.
And just because I see that there, I'll
even get my completions
running.
Bruce should have done that automatically.
Alright. Okay. Cool.
Alright.
So the first thing we need to do
is install a Timoni module.
So
let's just make sure I understand exactly what's
gonna happen here and just kind of share
this with the people that are watching.
When we say install a module, what we're
suggesting is that there's somebody
out there, you in this case has written
a Timoni module, thrown it to OCI, and
we can just consume that without doing anything
right off the bat. We could just say,
Timoni apply,
point it to it, and it's gonna throw
something into our Kubernetes cluster. Is that correct?
Yeah. You also need to specify the namespace
where that thing is.
Where that's oh, sorry. No. Where that's going
to deploy to in the cluster, right? Yes.
Yes. Does that use the context namespace,
or does it actually enforce that we specify
at runtime? No.
If
you don't specify it, it goes to default,
but if you have changed your default context,
it will use that. So Timoni,
CLI is built on top of
the
kubectl
runtime
package,
the CLI runtime, I think. So it has
all the flags from
kubectl
and knows all things that kubectl knows.
Default context,
default namespace, and so on.
Cool.
Alright. Well, let's just do a deploy to
the default namespace.
And just because I'm always curious, right, if
I remove dash dash version latest, does it
default to latest?
Sure.
Let's see.
Maybe to let her out and say, hey.
You you really need to specify Adam.
Think
Why? But I don't see your
console.
Oh,
I shut my whole window.
What happened?
Window.
Oh, I shared window not screen.
There we go.
Alright. So
yeah, I just did the Timoni apply, I
removed the namespace, I removed the latest,
my key chain is
asking for stuff
and there we go.
So it's applying this to my cluster.
So we could run kubectl,
get pods,
watch,
and it kinda beat me, but we do
have a pod and full deployed 10 ago.
Also, Timoni does a watch
and when you apply it. And it waits
for all the pods to be healthy.
Yeah. So if I run this again, I'm
assuming it's just gonna say there's nothing to
do.
Unchanged, unchanged, unchanged.
Yeah. You
also mentioned during your talk
that we could run a
diff.
Gonna say unchanged. So that's doing a server
side apply dry run. Cool.
Alright. I like it when things
just work the way I expect them to
work. It's always an absolute bonus.
Okay. So yeah, that's just a Timoni module
deployed to our cluster. So now we can
use Timoni to inspect our cluster to work
out what Timoni has deployed.
Now you said during your presentation that this
is not storing secrets.
So is this using,
No. That's not in cluster. This is actually
inspecting the module.
Okay. So it has the secret. It creates
a secret. And it doesn't store inside the
secret any
Kubernetes resources. Ah, Okay. Okay. I misunderstood that.
So if we run get secrets
or we do have a Timoni deployment secret.
Yeah. And it's a custom secret type
instance.
Okay.
And if I look at this, we just
get
the instance
base 64 encoding.
And this is,
again, I'm super curious. I always wanna know.
So I'm just gonna decode it.
Did I copy too much?
Again.
Hey.
Why is it doing that?
Copy.
Do it twice because that always fixes it.
Right?
Yeah.
Oh, no. I think it's actually just decoding
it in line, isn't it? There we go.
Yeah. So this is
a JSON instance, the CR. All right. Okay.
Got it. So
this is not a custom resource deployed to
my cluster because we haven't deployed anything to
money specific to my cluster. This is just
a CRD like object that Timoni understands for
what it has deployed to the cluster. Yeah.
Cool. Alright. Yeah. I was I was
I I
my first instinct was,
I should have a CRD and CR instead
of creating a secret. I should create a
custom resource.
But that would
kind of beat the purpose of creating a
CLI. A CLI should just work. So then
if you would,
if I would store this information in a
custom resource,
then you have to initialize Timoni on every
cluster, so register the CRDs and so on.
So I reserve that for a time where
there will be a Timoni controller
serializing this as a JSON and put it
in a secret for now, I think. It
does the job, and the UX is better.
You just don't apply and delete no initialization
of versioning of CIDs and so on.
But you can inspect what's inside the secret
with
with the inspect command. And it will it
will show you different things from what serialized
there.
Alright. Let's take a look at that then.
I
can't copy and paste today whatsoever.
Alright. So let's remove the namespace just because
I didn't use one to make my life
more complicated.
And we see the digest, the name, the
repository, and the version that was deployed.
Nice.
Yeah. And if you do inspect values
values for the info, you haven't set any
values,
and it gives you the default values.
Alright. I have put in the module as
default.
And
here is what
characteristic
of Timoni modules
compared to hand charts and everything. It comes
with a specification
for container images.
So Timoni is aware of what images are
in a module,
what tags are there, and if you specify
digest, it will use digest everywhere.
And
the vet command of a module will actually
tell modulators,
hey, you should set the digest. It's empty.
And you can also do, for example, Timoni
status
for the info.
And this will also list the images. So
when you do a status, it's about, Okay,
what things I have deployed? Is my deployment
available? Whatever, whatever. This is very different from
For Helm, a status of a release is
stored
after the upgrade or install is done.
Timoni does not do that because I think
an app is
alive on the cluster. It can fail after
an upgrade.
So what Timoni status does
is it queries the live cluster and does
a health check for everything at this moment.
Even if the upgrade worked like one hour
ago, maybe now you are out of capacity
and the things that you thought are ready
at upgrade time, now they are failing. So
status is a live command
that goes through every single resource and
uses a thing from the Kubernetes project, which
is called kstatus.
We also use it in Flux,
which knows how to help check
built in resources like deployment spots and so
on, but also custom resources which have already
status condition.
Okay.
So
this tells us the deployment is available in
the replicas as one. If I change the
replicas on the deployment to two, does it
just say deployment is available replicas two, or
does it tell us that there's draft from
what we applied?
Let's
configure
now podinfo and make it
change the configuration for it from the
Oh, you want to change it here? Yeah,
of course. It will just delete
replicas too.
Right? Status does not
do a dry run or Alright. Okay. K.
That's what I was curious. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Got it. Alright.
Sweet.
Okay. So
where's our status command? We've already kind of
done that now. So then we have the
ability to begin to configure our module by
providing our own queue value.
So to do that, we have a queue
blob like this, and then we're just running
our apply command again. However, we can specify
dash dash values and point it to a
CUE file.
So
greater values on CUE.
And
we can
see what's going on here. So this is
configured under resource requests, CPU and memory,
and then setting the limits to be the
exact same. I'm assuming we could also do
replicas
three like so.
You have to look in the readme. I
don't know if it's replicas.
Is that am I jumping ahead of something
that's already in this? No.
No. No. No.
Alright. Well, I mean, even if I break
it, it's fine because Timoni will tell me,
right? Yeah.
So I can just say we wanna run
a test, let's do a server side, apply
with a test and specify the values to
be my values.
So we've got a value change. The metadata
generation obviously changed. The spec replicas changed just
like I was hoping it would.
And we get this as a resources here.
I love this visual output as well. This
is very clear exactly what is changing. And
this is really difficult to get with other
tools in this space. So that's very nice.
Hey. Did you actually saved value skew? I
did. Yeah.
Why? What can what
why were you curious?
Okay.
Yeah. I I didn't see save it. Okay.
You can apply
now. Yes.
Worse that could happen.
Oh,
no. I forgot my my okay. I shouldn't
have removed
It's myself there.
Sweet.
And now it's waiting for our three pods
to become ready.
Yep.
And
if you
stop this and you
do a status, the status should say progressing
in rollout gives you more
details basically
about what's happening.
Right. Let's do that. So I'll make this
a bit more challenging for the cluster.
We'll do the apply.
I think get to this point and then
run our status.
Tounding enough because it did it already.
Yeah. Put info is very fast. It's tiny.
Plus it's a local Kubernetes customer where damage
is already built. So really, we're not gonna
They need to scan the single node. Yeah.
Alright. Well, because I always
am perpetually
curious,
Let's do something else. Right? So
I don't know if it's in the the
documentation here. I don't want us to drift
off course too much. Right? But if I
want to overwrite the image that is used
for pod info, how would I do that?
Can I do that for the values? Of
course. Alright.
So walk me through that because
I don't know. Do I just do containers?
No.
Alright.
No. Let's
look at the default values.
Okay. We got that from
inspect values and specter. Right? Yeah.
Okay. I gotcha. So we can say
image
repose in fact, let's change the image tag
to be a value that doesn't exist. Right?
So image
tag
v
twelve point one point two point three. Okay,
so it has to be
I suspect here,
let's do it at first, let's not suspect
anything.
Once I update the image and it's gonna
downgrade
our
replicas back to two. And now we can
do an apply,
set the test.
This is gonna say that the image can
come, but I wanna see this from
it is
an m progress pending termination.
Can I do a status? Is there, like,
a watch or something on this?
No. The the apply would
would have waited and report that
it can move forward.
And this is not Timoni's
future. As I said, it's case status, which
determines, oh,
the progress deadline for Podinfo is sixty seconds.
So after one need to say, I'm not
waiting anymore because, you know, there
isn't much to to wait for, it's it's
gone. It can move forward.
And it yeah, it basically
depends on the progress deadline that you set
on your deployments. Right? Also, Timoni apply has
a timeout
flag.
I think I set the default to five
minutes. But if you are you're deploying
stateful sets that are taking half hour, you
should set timeout half hour and just wait
for it. Right? It's
Yeah. I guess what I was curious about
is is this going to surface the image
peel back off? But I
guess not.
Not because
for now, it's because the replica set,
the deployment has not yet given up on
the replica set. Okay.
Right? It's initial back off.
So it does a
back off for, I think
yeah. It also depends on what your deadline
is set in a deployment. I think I've
set it to sixty seconds or ten ten
minutes for Podinfo.
Yeah. It's okay. I'll stop taking this off
course with my my sassy kudos. No. It's
great.
So I I set it back. I removed
it. I removed my customization,
and we're now running the standard version. So
we can run through the rest of the
tutorial, see if there's any questions from the
audience, and then I can go roll, give
you one, and say, okay. Oh, you can
you can do something
interesting here. Let's
see with Helm. If you have Helm values,
you can set some random thing that doesn't
exist in the chart, then Helm will apply
it, right?
Let's specify
a random field in the values that's not
in the module at all.
All right.
Okay.
Let's do this.
Ah, values Rawkode field not allowed.
So
what these things does is basically you as
the
owner of the app, the author of the
module,
when you define
what things
end users
can fiddle with with your app, the options,
also the users have this
error in front of them. Hey, you are
setting something that wasn't configured
is not allowed because that type of configuration
is not something that the module knows about.
So there is no point in going forward.
Other tools like Customize or whatever, specify a
patch to something that doesn't exist, to just
move and do its thing.
What I think
when you distribute applications,
you should
you know, ensure
correctness of the configuration, not let the user
think it has set something and it has
actually changed, while in fact there's not even
allowed. And that saves you from typos,
bad indentation,
and all of that. This is the power
of CUE in a way. It's Timoni just
surface
surfaces that as errors be applied.
Nice.
So I noticed that
nothing in my directory at this point in
time, because we're working with an OCI artifact.
Like, these
you know, we we can use the status
and the values command. Right? Inspect values. And
we can see what these values are.
It's it's cached on a disk somewhere, like
the queue definitions that people can look at
if they want to, or is that where
the bundles come in and where things start
to get vendored into package or etcetera?
If
you want to see the default values, you
say?
Well, yeah. If I wanted to
see the actual definition
for this to see
what is allowed.
Yeah. Or you can do Timoni mod pool.
And I'm gonna need that
string.
Yep.
Oh, I put path.
Yes there.
It's a
Oh, yeah. It's okay.
Help.
Did I set the output path?
Output.
Okay.
It should work with minus one.
Because the directory just has to exist.
If you put
Ah, there we go. Yeah. The directory just
have to exist.
Yeah. This actually someone
opened a pull request today to fix this.
You can create a directory if it doesn't
exist.
Right? So
now you can see the source. And usually
what you should do is look at the
Readme
markdown. We don't need Readme's.
Right? You don't need Readme's.
There
is a table there, like for hand charts
with all the possible configurations
and whatever.
But let's say you don't want to look
at it. It means you have two things
where you can
see how the values are. So the default
values are in values. Queuing the root of
the module. Yep.
And here are just images
normally.
If you want to see the whole schema
of the values, you go templates config dot
queue.
It's the first file. And here you see
all the things that you can set with
some defaults,
with types.
Right? So you have affinity,
you have pull secrets, all the things that
you would expect from, I don't know,
Kubernetes is most relevant. Right? You need to
specify all things and understand all things about
it.
So yeah, I don't think this should actually
be the way people should write modules.
I think
you should expose
you should
put in there good defaults,
and they should just toggle some
things,
like auto scaling enabled. And all default should
be good. I don't know. 99
CPU or whatever.
Would
I think the fact that we
ship
app configurations
without
good defaults,
people are now accustomed to do a deep
dive there and
set half of the fields in all the
Kubernetes things, it's like
we put too much pressure on the engine.
We should at least have a default
secure first configuration with all things in there
or production configuration and so on. And only
request people
what they really need to add as inputs,
passwords,
certificates,
all these things.
But yeah, the podinfo
Timoni module is
a replica of the podinfo
chart.
And that's why it doesn't have all defaults.
But I wanted to have this exercise like,
Okay, I have this M chart. It's been
used by, don't know. It has like millions
deployments. Let me just replicate it and see
how I can do this with Timoni.
Yeah.
Yeah. So let me clarify my thinking then
just to provide a bit more context about
why I was asking this. There's two reasons
I was asking this. Right? Because I think
it really surfaces why Timoni is so powerful
and so good. Right? Is one,
the CUE team are working on a language
server protocol, an LSP. So the author and
experience can become a lot better when you
pull
the module locally or vendor it into your
bundle.
Because then when you're in Versus Code, it
can auto complete all the types based on
the CUE definitions generated from the Timoni,
I can't remember the command. I think it
was just vendor CRD,
right? Which is very nice.
But also one of the superpowers now that
we're invested into the CUE
ecosystem
programme community, whatever you wanna call that there
is that as we start to build out
Timoni bundles that consume multiple
modules from across
anywhere, right? Where we're in a position here.
We can now use CUE and say, well,
our org
pod security policy,
maybe you just wanna make this
value like this, Could be blah blah blah,
not that important. And then as we consume
other modules, we can then just say pod
security
policy.
It's our org one, but when you need
to override it, you can do that. So
you don't have like one of the huge
problems with Helm is trying to apply policy
across
whale amount of
third party external charts for deploying Postgres,
MariaDB, MongoDB, operators here, controllers here,
whatever.
It just requires so much YAML duplication and
pain, but we actually have with CUE the
ability to tidy up and make things actually
consumable. And I'm sure Timoni has other layers
into that, but we've not even covered yet.
So again, I don't wanna take us too
far off where we're supposed to be going
through because we are running way over where
we wanted to be time wise. So I
just wanna check that you're okay for us
to continue through the quick start and finish.
Are you okay for time? Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Cool. Sorry. Me going off road is always
gonna be a challenge.
So
this is really cool. I'm I'm loving what
we're seeing. So let's let's let's finish the
quick start and take a look at the
secret stuff in the production application of Right?
And then I've not looked at the questions
in ages, I'm sorry, in live viewers, but
I'll check it in just a moment.
But we're let's do our delete. It's all
gone.
Come back to our tutorial
and now we can start to play with
bundling instances together.
And I'm gonna copy this because we're going
to do a bundle
apply.
So let's close all this
bundle
here.
What this is doing is saying we wanna
bundle
going to call this pod info V one
alpha one, where we're going to deploy a
Redis
module and the same pod info bundle that
we've already deployed. However, this time we are
going to enable caching and point at this.
And we got this.
And call mains the same as yours because
terrible person.
There we go.
So let's handle like
one of the practical questions that I'm sure
it's gonna come from audience and this even
in my head. Right? It's like
people watch this, but they're holy shit. This
is amazing. I'm convinced. I'm their team Timoni.
That's it. Let's go.
Are they working with Timoni modules? Are they
always working with bundles? Are they always writing
their own bundles that consume modules? Like, I
am dual blogs developer.
I turn up to work tomorrow. I say,
hey team, this is what we do now.
Do they start writing their own bundle right
away and consume third party modules or do
they just deploy modules? Like how do you
see that working?
Let me give you a concrete example because
that's that's very abstract. Right? I'm Dropbox developer.
I'm going to work tomorrow. I wanna deploy
MongoDB
and a web application.
What's the first thing I do?
Well, there is no Timoni module for MongoDB.
So you could spend a lot of time
writing that from zero.
Then you have to write the module for
your own app, and you should definitely publish
those to
Container Registry and use bundles and not rely
on best scripts
that are calling
setting values to this file and so on.
You should definitely use bundles and do a
simple apply of that and have in the
bundle everything.
I'm guessing the PVC is failing because maybe
your cluster does not have it. We knew
that was gonna I assured you it would
be okay,
and
now I feel bad.
I
don't have
Let's look at the pod info namespace and
see what's happening there.
Hey. I didn't specify a namespace to the
bundle. You did in the bundle. Mhmm.
Ah, right. Gotcha. Okay.
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah.
So
we do have one though.
Why is the claim
pending?
Because you're not using the default storage class.
It's not you, but, you know, it's looking
for a standard default class rather than the
default default class. Yeah. Okay. So we can
actually
change it.
Oh, I'm gonna can I pull a bundle?
What? I would pull the module. Right? I
do a module pull.
Pull the reddest module.
I wanna I wanna see if I can
do this.
Okay.
So Timoni
module
tool.
I don't know what's buying my my copy
and paste just hits me today. Right?
Output,
Redis. And we know that this now needs
to exist first. So make sure
is
not module pool.
Mod.
Alright. So let's go back to Versus Code.
Then I open something else. That's okay.
Templates config. So now I know Oh, don't
have to scroll much. Yeah. So I can
just set persistence storage class.
So let's do this
up.
I can tell you no queue
because most people wouldn't know to, you know,
wrap it in values.
I have done a lot with CUE. I
actually have a couple of tools I built
on top of CUE myself, so I'm very
familiar with it.
Now my storage class is called local path.
Now I could just leave this as blank,
which would pull the default, but
we'll do it this way.
No. It should be oh, that's that's the
name. Okay.
Yeah. That's the name. But I mean, we
could just force it to blank, which would
tell the cluster to use the default storage
class. Let's let's let's try it. Right? Yeah.
So let's just
pull that
and then we'll do our 20 bundle apply.
And if we just come down here,
oh, it's immutable.
Yeah.
Let's do a force apply.
I was going to just delete the claim,
but I guess this also works.
And then if we do a GET
PVC.
So
Timoni
does, it has code that detects immutable errors
returned by the Kubernetes API. And when you
set it to force or you can also
add annotations
for those objects, it will recreate them. But
force tells
Timoni, hey, look for immutable errors. And if
there are any immutables, only then recreate the
object. Don't destroy objects which
don't have immutable changes to immutable fields inside.
Force is quite
special.
Yeah. Well, even when I set the storage
class, it's still failing, so that's my bad.
But it's okay. We planned for this. I
planned for this.
And my
that's a lot of downloads.
And my downloads folder, I'll check the name
over here to spare everybody the mess of
my downloads folder. I have a CUE config
file, which we will nicely put here where
I will export CUE config equals
EWTKC.
And we will do
that actually worked. Worked. And
I was gonna go to my backup cube.
So get PVC.
So it's just a slow
oh, we got it. Nice. Awesome.
And it
also has end to end tests. So if
we look a little bit at what the
output of the bundle applies,
you'll see that
it goes into stages.
And the module creators,
the software vendors,
they have
control over stages.
And they can
instruct Timoni how to apply things in stages,
do health checks, run end to end tests,
then move to another thing. For example,
orchestrating a Redis deployment, in my case, is
first you create a masternode
with a persistent claim. You wait for that
to be healthy.
Then you create a replica
set, the Redis
replicas.
And at the end, you run an end
to end test to make sure that the
cluster is in good shape and only then
move to the app that uses
what it is.
Ah, that was so subtle. I didn't notice
that, but you're right. Look, we have
service icon config map and register.
Then
it has the replicas. And then I I
I just didn't even notice the job with
the registers. Nice.
Yeah. So what does that look like in
TimoniQ?
Is that in the this here?
Yeah.
Ah, so you can have multiple apply steps
like so.
Then you have conditions.
If
the end user wants to run the test
and the test is enabling values only then
do the
test jobs.
And
how Timoni treats tests is yet very different
from what Helm does. For Timoni,
tests are part
of the desired state.
They are not some
afterthought that they can exist. There is no
test command. You don't run tests out of
nothing.
How tests are part of the desired state,
and every time,
if you run now again the apply, there
will be no test run,
because the desired state didn't change. But if
you change a value,
then Timoni will regenerate
the job and run the test because you
want to run tests
only when things change.
So that's also a big
difference
in how it does it.
Oh yeah. It's unchanged, right? But if you
change something in your Redis configuration,
the computed checks some of the desired set
changes. And that
tells Timoni, hey, I have to wipe out
the old job,
clear it out
also along with all the pods, and run
a new test. So yeah, tests are quite
different.
Here in TimoniQ,
where the module authors have the whole power
of defining how the apply works, you can
also
set here
things like, I want to apply this only
if
an object does not exist on the cluster.
And this is how you can do the
same stuff as have
pre installed hooks.
Because Timoni has no hooks. It's always an
apply. There is
no install. There is no upgrade. It's apply,
right? But you can
have
same Timoni, apply this only if it doesn't
exist or apply it anytime or clean it
up after you applied it.
So
that's how we can do prerequisites
for an installation or prerequisites only for upgrades
and so on.
Alright.
Quick question then.
This
I'm
just curious how you look over these stages.
Right? Because
there's no specific ordering other than the order
that you've put them inside of this file.
And so does
CUE maintain that order?
Well, yeah, of course. Uh-huh. I actually didn't
know that. Nice. Okay. Very cool. So I'm
using the AST to work
the CUE files.
So if the file is one and the
other, why wouldn't I execute it in that
direction?
Okay.
So you're not actually just rendering out the
concrete value. You're working with the queue value
itself as part of Timoni.
So Yeah. There are many, many things that
Timoni does around queue files. It's that
Some files get directly compiled
for other files. I'm working DST from other
files. I'm doing unifying.
Yeah. It's
it was quite an adventure, but I like
it in a way. Yeah. I learned a
lot a lot of queuing.
Alright.
Let's
tackle the question and then we'll do the
secret stuff and then we'll finish up for
today's session. So
Daniel says, this looks so good. Awesome. We
glad you like this, Daniel. Why I'm always
asking if we can touch on and I'll
say we, but I mean you, Stefan.
Could you touch on what this looks like
for working with two separate teams,
like a platform team and a dev team
working with bundles
as in maybe two separate repos managed by
the same app from two separate teams with
different concerns.
Let's see if I can put that sentence
together in a way that I understand. Do
you know what why I'm always asking there,
Stefan?
So from a platform team perspective and dev
teams or operations team, right Yeah. There are
several approaches here. I imagine the platform team
will want to design Timoni modules
for
generic modules for node GS apps
that have the right, I don't know, NGINX,
sidecar,
that exposes metrics,
the
node
GS
app container
limits,
all things in there. Right? Then
dev team, when they want to deploy their
own
NGINX
app,
they will use a bundle. They will set
their own images. Maybe they will do some
little configuration of that deployment, but they will
use in the bundle those
standard modules created by platform teams. That's one
way to do it, and you don't need
the repo. You don't need to look in
the repo. The platform team will publish all
these modules to the internal Container Registry.
Right? And app developers, app teams will just
use those modules
from there. That's one approach. And maybe it's
too strict. Maybe
app teams want to develop their own modules,
so maybe the platform team will only create
these CUE libraries,
which abstract away a
bunch of stuff in Kubernetes, and they will
do Timoni artifact push of that particular
CUE library. And when
the app team creates their own modules, they
will do artifact pool. Okay, I want to
use all these components and I'm writing my
own module because I know best how to
configure, how to expose my app configuration.
Then
the operation team will create a bundle using
either modules created by the platform team or
the app team or the app team themselves.
They will
have good bundles for everybody to deploy and
they'll publish those and
operations team can use those bundles. It's like,
it really depends on your organization structure and
how teams are collaborating between them.
I think Timoni and and and CUE modules
themselves offer a lot of
flexibility here.
So, yeah, I don't think there is one
way of doing it, but it's quite flexible.
The idea is that at the end, someone
will create a bundle that will use
all these modules created by someone else or
themselves.
Yeah. I'm gonna touch on that with my
own opinion just a little bit as well,
which is very much in line with what
you were saying, but just for why it
was a question. Right? It's like, there's two
things that when you're talking about working with
platform teams and dev teams. Right? There's two
different constraints that are important here. One, the
platform team is gonna say to deploy to
our cluster, you must
do this. Right? There's policies, there's enforcement.
And that's always gonna happen in the cluster
via admission controllers of some variety and they
will enforce that there. However, what I think
why I'm always also touching on is that
you may be in a position where if
you can get buy in where the dev
teams and the platform teams are using Timoni,
the platform team for cluster add ons and
the dev teams for their applications.
You might get to a point where maybe
the platform teams are building some best practices
that people can consume.
And I think those could be Timoni modules
that are versioned and you can opt end
to those defaulting behaviors for security context and
policies and so forth. Even though there would
be a higher level of mission control somewhere.
So I think you you can just the
platform team or even the dev teams maybe
they do it, right? Maybe you're Amazon
and there's 5,000 dev teams working on 10,000
microservices
and you write out Timoni modules. This is
a good deployment strategy for our customers and
you can opt in to using that behavior
if you want. And because everything's versions and
there's digests,
yeah, you can opt into that. So
from an opt in perspective,
use the module system for any enforcement. I
think it has to be admission control. I
don't think Timoni would set in that pipeline
whatsoever.
Would you agree with that?
Yeah. I
no matter how much policy you you can
put on a client side,
Indian someone can do a KubeCatulated
right on the cluster. So you actually need,
unless you go full on GitOps, no one
connects to the cluster at all.
There is no way to
work around having webhooks. And webhooks are like
evil.
They will bring down your whole cluster, are
single point of failure for Kubernetes API. The
more webhooks you have, the slower everything gets.
Dry runs are really, really crazy hard to
do with webhooks and so on. But that's
where we are. That's the reality. Right? Sadly,
yeah, we need to run these webhooks,
and when they go down, they take everything
down. And good luck saving a cluster
if your webhooks are are in the crash
Yes. We've all been there.
Why I wanted follow-up on our question. So
they said they didn't think about sharing via
bundles, but I hope that is interesting path
two.
But they have said, how do we guarantee
that the dev team always use the latest
bundles from the platform team?
Is that possible?
The latest modules maybe.
Yeah. The latest modules. So, you know, if
the platform team does provide a module, is
there any way for them to make sure
the dev teams are always upgrading to the
latest and greatest?
No.
Yeah. Unless you don't specify a version in
the bundle. And every time you do an
apply, Timoni will look which is the latest
and and it will pull latest. But if
you use a digest or a version, you
pin that
module to a particular version.
Of course, we can roll out with latest
everywhere,
every time you don't apply, it will be
latest. But,
yeah, I'm not sure is that the best
approach. No. I I I don't I don't
think that's a good pattern. I'll go back
to what I said. Like, it's
when you're using these Timoni module, I I
feel like you opt in to the latest
version because you're comfortable, you've tested it, you're
happy with it. If any enforcement has to
happen, it has to be in mission control.
So I wouldn't do that this way.
But we hope that helps. Alright. We've got
one more thing to show, I I believe,
which is let's
mildly productionize
this bundle
and do some sort of secret injection. So
you did share with me
a guest,
which is here,
which let's just copy and paste it first,
and then we can run through on why
or how this is different. And this actually
also correlates to another question, the why I'm
all asked at the start of this session.
So we will tackle that too.
So my bundle. Queue, that's in the right
one.
Now here
you were specifying that we have some value
for a password
using the queue attribute where we're saying that
this password will come from a runtime string,
which is
assuming either a flag or an environment variable
on the Timoni CLI.
And this is then used
just to augment the values.
And it's also interpreted down here to the
Redis URL.
Is that the only changes in this file?
Yeah. Yeah.
I think there are more
more things.
Yeah. You can delete test enabled
through. I don't think that was in the
original one. Yeah. Delete that's the test for
Timoni for
you could disable
test for Redis.
So we only
Yeah. So what's important here is
there's a secret value that you wanna inject
into
your Timoni application.
We're saying let's get it from runtime. That's
all that's important here. And then we use
that to set the value on the Redis
deploy and interpolate it into the connection string
for the pod info. So let's copy the
command
just down here. And I think there are
multiple ways to do this, but
I'm I'm guessing right now. So let's check.
Right?
So if we paste this, what we're seeing
here is the reddest password is test,
and we're doing a bundle that
on bundle dot queue and run time from
env.
So
are there multiple ways to provide runtime values
beyond the environment? That's my first question.
Yeah. You want to do
yeah. That is for very dynamic. You want
to do an apply instead of that.
Yeah, so what we have here is
typically for
a CI system, right? You have some
I claim.
Claim. Yes.
Yeah, so in
a CI system, right, you can have these
secret stores.
I know, GitHub has one. GitLab, everybody has
it. Right? And
what you can do is read
from the CI secret source,
set an environment variable from that thing, and
then pass that through the environment variable to
the Timoni apply command.
And Timoni does not read environment variables by
default, so you need to actually tell Timoni,
hey, use the runtime from the environment,
because
this is something specific to local testing.
Say, read this password equals something, Timoni apply,
which that's just an environment variable setting, right?
It's not something specific to me that's
from the command line. Or we can do
an export
and so on.
But if you are
applying from CI, you can pass in this
way secrets through the environment
and inject them in the bundles.
Because the bundles usually where they are stored
in the Git repo, you shouldn't be placing
any sensitive information in there
if there is a way around it.
If you want to place sensitive information in
there, there
is documentation on Timoni website how you can
use SOPS,
the CLI,
encrypt some JSON or YAML file. And then
when you do a bundle apply besides the
CUE file, you can also tell Timoni, hey,
read from this
YAML file that's decrypted there in place by
SOPS and then removed and goes through the
memory and all the SOPS
operation model.
So this is one way of doing it,
right? But
when
secrets are in CI. But usually with Kubernetes,
you'd have some
external secret
controller,
or secrets are
arrived into NTCD from Vault, or stuff like
that. So in most cases, you will have
these
secret values in some
resource inside the cluster.
How there is a way with
Timoni runtimes
to tell Timoni, hey, query the cluster for
a Kubernetes secret, extract this field from here,
then use this field as the runtime value
inside the bundle.
Right? And
we can actually set the the password now
from from the cluster. So you should go
back to the gist. You will
have to create a Kubernetes secret.
So this has created a secret in
the default namespace. Now we have to create
this other file, which is a runtime.
Runtime definition. Why is this different? Because
runtimes can be reused across bundles. If you
have many bundles which have to connect to
the same Redis cluster or whatever, use same
thing.
You can reuse the runtime to not write
the query
every time.
Yeah. There is an error because diff does
not work on immutable
things, but
it has changed the
password here. And also, if you go up,
you will see the new password for the
Redis
replicas and the master
things.
Nice. And
this basically has queried the cluster for the
secret. It went to the secret and this
is how you can specify that query.
Yeah. This is one of my my favorite
features. Like, coming back to that whole platform
dev thing from the question earlier, you know,
like the platform team goes on to hopefully
puts out a lot of effort to provide
in the platform with all of the
end cluster add ons that you need, the
external secrets operator hooked up to KMSs or
vaults,
you know, DNS records, all those external bulbs
that you need for your application to actually
run successfully and being able to do this
sort of dynamic lookup
and inject this into this money runtime. I
think it just
simplifies a whole lot of what we're trying
to do,
especially when you start getting into get ups
and you've got controllers and things like that
there. Because I mean there is a Timoni
controller right? That runs all of this in
cluster for you. No. No, I thought there
was.
Alright. That's next week's mission Stefan.
All right, this is awesome. Very, very cool.
So
I think we're showing everything right? I'll stop
sharing my screen. Right, cool. So if anyone
has any last minute questions now is your
time to get them in for Stefan before
we wrap up. This session has gone on
a little bit longer than we did anticipate,
but I've had a whole lot of fun.
So just, thank you so much Stefan for
joining me and guiding us through this. If
you're happy to, well, we just wait a
few minutes for any last minute questions. Sure.
What what's next? Like, what's what's on your
roadmap for for Timoni?
So I have this proposal around
multi cluster deployments where the runtime definition that
you've played with,
the size values will also have a list
of clusters.
So you can run a single apply command
that will target all these clusters, and it
will get values from each cluster,
and so on.
That's that's one of my
things that I would like to do,
next when I have the time to work
on it.
Yeah. And slowly, want to
know
it all depends in the end on the
amount of people using it and the feedback
I'm getting
for it. But I would be like, I
don't know, Q1 next year to stabilize the
API. Everything is V1 alpha one right now.
I think I have a good
I have some good concepts
implemented there.
Could just label it
v one, beta one, but I I
yeah. It took us three years to make
Flux version two GA, and I'm not the
type of person that rushes into
labeling things GA
or stable.
So I think I will
wait more before
getting more and more users, more feedback, and
and stabilize the API.
Only after the API is in stable shape
can be a discussion around the Timoni controller
for Flux, the Timoni controller on its own
or whatever whatever
the options are.
Also, around controllers,
I
really don't like the idea that you would
be you'll have to write the bundle in
a YAML file
because
KubeCTL apply or the API server does not
understand CUE. It only understands YAML
or JSON or Kubernetes
objects.
So maybe I'll write my Kubernetes API server
extension
that you can do on that. It actually
understands CUE, and you don't need to
write YAML at all
to receive
the CUE and do the things there. I'm
not sure.
There are so many ideas floating around.
But yeah, at some point there will be
a controller.
How it will look? What I know for
sure is that I don't want
for the custom resource to be a representation
of an instance. I want the custom resource
to be a representation of a bundle, because
that's a proper app definition made out of
many pieces with things,
inputs from the cluster, and so on. So
I think that would be,
the API object that that Kubernetes will will
deal with.
Yeah.
I know not
to go too far off track. Right? But
going over to the Flex CT stage of
things, there was a discussion, I think, some
point last year
about potentially allowing the customized controller to duct
tape the sources. Is that something that's still
being considered?
Do you know what I mean by that
or should I wouldn't worry Duct tape. The
source. Duct tape. Sorry. It's my Scottish accent.
So you know how the customized controller has
got hard coded references to like the OCI
repository, the GET repository, etcetera. Like if we
could just say it accepts anything that has
these sets of fields on this on the
status or spec and it doesn't have to
be one of those, you know, duct typing.
Right? It just it looks like a source
provider, but it does it's not one that
we know of.
Would that simplify things for a Timoni controller
where you could have
a simple controller that monitored the OCI repository,
run the Timoni command in the cluster and
spy out a new source? Like, that that
seems like it would be a nice approach.
No. No?
Definitely not.
Alright. I'll show that. That's quite something that's
about customized. It does patches,
which shouldn't be in any way something that
you deal with Timoni. Right? Timoni has the
stage apply,
all of that. Right? It should be the
Timoni reconciler that
sets the cluster state,
not customized controller, which does customized things. And
also those plain Kubernetes YAML manifest was the
part I was thinking about hooking into. Right?
It's just have a Timoni
controller that just spits out the the YAML
for the customized controller to apply. That's already
how you can do it. You do
I can't do it in cluster, right? I
would have to I would have to run
it locally, generate the YAML, and push it
somewhere, right? Yeah.
Yeah. You can run a registry in cluster.
Very tiny. There are many registries out there
that can run-in cluster. But I think a
Timoni controller should be an applier
before anything because it has its own
mechanisms
which are very different from Flux customized controller
or Flux Helm controller.
Yeah.
Well, we can schedule a livestream for how
long do you need to write that? Two
weeks? Three weeks?
Don't know.
Yeah, maybe.
The API is all set,
which is the most important thing right now.
And I also like to get
good feeling of is the user experience for
authoring CUE modules
good?
Are going people are people going to write
modules? If if they aren't and
CUE is not appealing to them,
why would I continue this project? I'll just
archive it and move move forward. It's
very tied to the language.
Alright.
Yeah. I'd be very sad to see that.
I know the CUE team are actively working
on their language server implementation.
I know I spoke to Paul Jolley recently,
and he said that that was his next
job
is to improve that authoring experience for people
actually rating CUE. I know they're also handling
the module stuff, but you covered that earlier
on in the session. So. Yeah. I I
mean, for me, the fact that you can
share,
bits of CUE easily is
not the top problem for me with CUE.
My my my
major issue with CUE is definitely a lack
of a language server. I cannot do go
to definition. I don't have auto completion. I
don't have anything. It's all the things that
are supposed to have because everything is type
safe. Everything is so nice. Like when it
comes to the editor,
you are in V mode with nothing else,
right? Not even
yeah, I don't know. Even
writing YAML
has auto completion now for Kubernetes in Versus
Code and IntelliJ.
CUE doesn't even have that. So, yeah, unless
they get there, I don't see how people
will
enjoy writing CUE.
Yeah. Also, Copilot does not understand CUE, which
is kind of fun.
It'll get there. These are all easy things
to fix. I hope. Right? And I I
hope these will be fixed quickly and in
six months time at the next CUE con
in Paris, can all Yeah. Have a laugh
and see things are much better now.
But but but we'll see, you know. Yeah.
I think we have any more questions from
the audience. So I'll just say again, thank
you so much. Like, I I think that's
one of the most interesting projects in the
CNCF landscape right now. I hope people,
one,
like what they're seeing and two, start going
out there doing tutorials, blogs, videos and contributing
wherever possible because you know, these open source
projects need momentum to keep it interesting
for you to be doing all the heavy
lifting and hard work. And I hope that
other people come along to help you with
that as well. Thank you again. Thank you
very much, David for inviting me. It was
like, this was my first ever talk on
Timoni and I really enjoyed it.
Awesome. Well, thank you all and feel free
to leave comments after the fact. I'll do
my best to route them to Stefan as
they come in and we'll see you all
next time. Have a wonderful weekend.